una partícula se mueve sobre la recta
numérica que no está dibujada cuando el
tiempo t es mayor o igual a 0 su función
de posición es cdt esta gráfica de en
azul así que la posición es esta curva
de aquí su velocidad vedete está en rojo
es esta curva de acá y su aceleración
adt está en verde que sería esta curva
de aquí todas las gráficas y funciones
consideran el tiempo t medido en
segundos apoyándote las gráficas
responden las preguntas a continuación
estas tres preguntas de aquí bueno
entonces antes que nada vamos a dibujar
la recta numérica que no nos quisieron
dibujar en el problema vamos a ponerla
por aquí más o menos se ve algo así por
aquí tendría el cero
por acá al 1
por acá el -1 y por acá al menos dos
bueno y qué me dicen estas gráficas como
las puede interpretar pues en el tiempo
te igual a cero ente igual a cero mi
posición es precisamente el cero así que
cuando t es igual a cero estoy parado
aquí
después me comienzo a mover y mi
posición se comienza a alejar del cero
mi distancia a cero está incrementándose
hasta que llegó a este punto al punto
que está a dos del cero la posición que
está 2 del 0 llegó a ese punto
precisamente cuando el tiempo es un
segundo entonces esta es mi posición
cuando t es igual a 1 y luego
simplemente comienzo a regresar hacia el
0 noten como la distancia al 0 va
disminuyendo entonces más o menos lo que
está pasando es que salgo el 0 con
muchísima velocidad no llegó al 2 me
detengo por un instante y luego comienza
a regresar como que me quedo a la deriva
y voy de regreso hacia el 0 y también me
dice esto es la gráfica de la velocidad
que recuerden es la derivada de la
función de posición la velocidad de una
partícula es la derivada de su función
de posición y
me está diciendo pues cuando te igual a
cero salgo con muchísima velocidad y
cada vez tengo menos velocidad
llego al 2 ente igual a 1
ay mi velocidad es cero porque estoy
instantáneamente detenido y luego
comienza a regresar la velocidad
negativa por lo tanto voy de regreso y
la aceleración nos cuenta una historia
similar pero bueno entonces la velocidad
inicial de la partícula es tantas
unidades por segundo y por favor
detengan el vídeo y traten de
responderlo por ustedes mismos pero
bueno cuál es la velocidad inicial de la
partícula pues simplemente me fijo en la
gráfica la velocidad y pongo t igual a
cero es ocho unidades por segundo ocho
unidades por segundo
ahora la partícula se mueve a la derecha
cuando t es miembro de qué cosa ahora
como tengo esta pertenencia aquí estoy
tratando de hacerlo con un intervalo con
juntista entonces bueno recuerden cuando
la partícula se está moviendo a la
derecha pues eso es equivalente a
preguntarnos cuando la velocidad
es positiva es mayor que 0 si la
velocidad es positiva la partícula se
está moviendo a la derecha si la
velocidad de 0 la partícula está
detenida y si la velocidad es negativa
la partícula viene de regreso hacia la
izquierda entonces bueno cuando es la
velocidad positiva pues la velocidad
positiva siempre que la gráfica roja
esté por encima del eje x es decir entre
así que esto es cierto cuando t
pertenece a el intervalo cero
hasta 1 pero el 1 no está incluido
porque en el 1 la velocidad de 0 por lo
tanto y la partícula está detenida por
lo tanto lo escribo así que está en el
intervalo semi abierto 0 1 que es
completamente equivalente a decir que 0
es menor o igual a t que es menor
estricto que 1
así que es la respuesta la distancia
total recorrida por la partícula cuando
te está en el intervalo 03 cerrado es
cuántas unidades bueno y está quizás sea
un poco más truculenta
recordemos que significa distancia total
porque no nos están pidiendo el
desplazamiento total sino la distancia
total si yo salgo de este punto y me
muevo digamos tres unidades hacia acá de
la derecha y luego regreso una unidad
podría decir que es recurrir menos uno
entonces mi distancia total recorrida mi
distancia total sería de tres unidades
más una unidad no me importa en qué
sentido voy así que la distancia total
sería 4 pero mi desplazamiento total mi
desplazamiento neto sería simplemente
puede salir a este punto y terminé en
este punto que está a dos unidades de
distancia por lo tanto el desplazamiento
sería de dos unidades
pero me están preguntando por la
distancia así que no me importa el
sentido en el que se esté recorriendo
todo pues veamos la partícula en el
instante 1 está en este punto está a una
distancia de dos unidades del origen y
luego comienza a regresar hasta que en
el instante 3 en el instante 3 que sería
este punto aquí está a 1.5 así que la
partícula se movió del 0 al 2 en un
segundo y luego en los 2 segundos
restantes regreso la mitad del camino
entre el 1 y el 2 así que llegaría aquí
a 1.5 entonces tengo 2 + 0.52 + 0.5
sería 2.5 unidades
esa es la distancia total recorrida por
la partícula o dos con un medio como
ustedes prefieran